previously on AI adventures we looked at
the tensor processing unit v1 how it
came to be and its design it only seems
right that we now go back and check out
TPU b2 and b3 what changes and
improvements were made to create these
new state-of-the-art chips and how can
you use them to power your machine
learning stay tuned to find out
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu phango
and on this episode we're going to take
a look at the architecture of the TPU v2
and v3 as well as how the hardware
design choices come together to create a
powerful specialized machine learning
chip after the TPU v1 was created the
team took the lessons they learned and
applied it to designing the TPU v2 as
you can see it's considerably larger
than the first TPU and features four
chips instead of just one additionally
it's got some massive heat sinks it has
a hundred and eighty teraflops of
compute meaning that it can do 180
trillion floating-point operations per
second and it does both training and
prediction now the layout of the TPU v2
is quite interesting each board has
those four chips but each chip has two
cores each core then contains a matrix
unit a vector unit and a scaler unit all
connected to eight gigabytes of high
bandwidth memory that means in total
each board has eight cores and 64 gigs
of memory and the matrix unit is a 128
by 128 systolic array what's special
about the TPU v2 though is its use of a
new data type called the B float16 the B
float16 combines the range of a 32-bit
floating-point number with just the
storage space of only a 16-bit floating
point number and what does the B&B
float16 stand for brain says it comes to
us from the Google brain
of course you can't get something for
nothing and what we lose is precision
the B float16 is able to represent far
fewer decimal places than a standard
16-bit floating point number however the
team determined that this was worth the
trade-off
since neural networks can operate at a
reduced precision while retaining
sufficiently high accuracy and using the
B float16 enabled the TPU v2 to fit in
much more computational power combined
with designing an integrated chip and
placing it on the board with three
compatriots so you have four chips per
board the TPU v2 achieves much higher
performance than the b1 now for the
really exciting part the TPU v2 is
arranged into pods one TPU v2 pod is 60
40 P use they're all connected together
and you can use an entire pod as if it
was one machine and since there are two
cores per chip with those four chips per
board and 64 TP use per pod that
multiplies out to 512 cores in a TPU pod
totaling up to over eleven petaflop s'
of processing power you can use smaller
subdivisions of the pods as well such as
say a quarter pod or a half pod what's
really extraordinary is when you start
using TPU pods to train up
state-of-the-art models on benchmark
data sets for example you can train
resin at 50 in 39 hours but thirty
minutes and that's only on a half pod
with just 32 TP use and when you look at
the training process used they're using
a batch size of 8000 images per batch
quite amazing and this is part of what
allows that training to proceed at such
a breakneck pace now I promised to talk
about TPU v3 as well so here it is as
you can see they took the v2 and they
made it blue but additionally of course
these chips use water cooling this
allows it to take up much less vertical
space so the TPU v3 pods can then
support many
warranty pues in it and a full TPU V 3
pod comes in at 8 times faster than a b2
pod and weighs in at over a hundred
petaflop s' of compute power today TP
use are available as individual boards
or as pod slices and both TPU v2 and TPU
v3 are available for you to use it only
costs a couple of dollars per hour
depending on which region used on which
TPU you choose pricing for TPU pods is
as you might imagine somewhat more
substantial with all those TPU is
connected together but for truly
large-scale training jobs that you need
to have run quickly
it is worth it programming the TPU is
just consistently getting easier and
easier with the recent release of
tensorflow 2.0 you can even use the
Charis api to code up your training for
cheap use there are great samples and
implementations of many state of the art
models so what you can do is just swap
in your custom data set and you're off
to the races you can learn more and get
started at Chico slash cloud TPU thanks
for watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it click
that like button and be sure to
subscribe to get all the latest episodes
right when they come out for now check
out cloud abuse and see how quickly they
can train your models at scale
you
[Music]